cosmetics we don't ingest them so
they're not tested for that but they
still are able to enter circulation
whether it's through hand to mouth
behavior they're able to get into our
skin we know that bpa for example is
able to get into our skin and enter
circulation like dental tape for example
dental tape is made of substances that
are used to make teflon or non-stick
pans and
yeah these are powerful endocrine
endocrine disruptors there's a whole
movie with mark ruffalo called dark
waters all about this fragrance products
we're told okay thanks to marketing
right that humans should smell a certain
way and that all bad odors are like you
know something that we want to like put
a chemical band-aid over fragrances are
among the most notorious they're made
using phthalates the term fragrance on a
cosmetic label could be an umbrella
which hides hundreds of chemicals under
that singular term yeah there's so many
and i think it's not worth going crazy
over because you're not going to be able
to completely eliminate your exposure
but in my view i think it's just
important to become aware